[Musique]
de nouveaux gestes sanitaires à adopter
et chaud poids obligatoire pour les
clients de nouveaux équipements à porter
pour les professionnels dans ce salon de
maurepas la reprise d'activité était
fortement attendu les quatre coiffes et
arrêté sur le pont dès l'ouverture
toutes les infractions a fait
l'essentiel vraiment essentiel donc les
tondeuses et sabots europe mais la voilà
on change de 4 pour cette première heure
de reprise la clientèle est plutôt
masculine et le rasage de près et de
rigueur
j'en pouvais plus demain couple a déjà
un peu long alors que d'habitude les
deux semaines du coup à l'air simple
important de me sentir comme avant j'ai
ici parce qu'il 13 donc forcément on
trouve pas forcément partout des gens
qui puissent stressé aussi facilement
et faire les choses proprement ça
devenait vraiment critique sur le jeu il
y avait vraiment beaucoup beaucoup de
temps qui me laisse en coin perdu au
profit de man après deux mois de
confinement ce salon accueille jusqu'à
40000 euros de perte de chiffre
d'affaires
ouvert depuis seulement octobre 2019
l'établissement a tout de même pu
profiter d'un prêt de l'état
on n'a pas été abandonnée il a prévu
quelques aides
on a réussi à faire un pg donc on s'en
sortent bien et on est aussi que passer
par une plate forme donc pour faire de
la bande de bons d'achat ce qui nous a
permis d'avoir un petit peu de
trésorerie au fur et à mesure pour
pouvoir payer les différentes charges
qui se présentaient dès la première
semaine on a été agréablement surpris on
a eu plus de 1000 euros donc de bons
d'achat donc sur la première semaine aux
mille euros sur un chiffre d'affaires
important peut-être que c'est rien mais
dans sur des situations franchement
c'est vraiment vraiment conséquent le
salon attend jusqu'à une vingtaine de
clients par jour le carnet de
rendez-vous est quasiment complet pour
la semaine